bonsoir à tous Bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
ça craque c'est le titre choc de votre
enquête François Xavier ménage bonsoir à
vous grand reporter à TF1 merci d'être
notre grand témoin vous signez un voyage
édifiant au cœur d'une France
silencieuse about mais pas résigné on en
parlera c'est un livre à mettre dans les
mains des responsables politiques pour
prendre la mesure concrètees des
problèmes qui existent dans notre pays
au plus près du terrain on on parle tous
les deux dans la deuxième partie notre
grand débat ce soir comment éviter
l'importation du conflit en France 5
jours après l'attaque terroriste du
ramas contre Israël les actes
antisémites se multiplie dans notre pays
Gérald d'manin demande au préfet
l'interdiction de toutes les
manifestations propalestiniennes en
France Emmanuel Macron s'apprendre à
prendre la parole il appelle au calme et
à l'unité nationale en a-t-il encore les
moyens nous en débattrons enfin nos
affranchis ce soir le philosophe Nathan
de Vert le Grand Reporter Vincent etjeu
et puis un Bourbon Express signé ce soir
Marco prier voilà pour le menu on y va
franç ménage ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti la crainte la crainte est dans
tous les esprits l'importation du
conflit est-elle évitable en France ce
soir donc géralde daranin demande au
préfet d'interdire les manifestations
proalestiniennes est-ce que c'est la
solution doit-on s'attendre à une
flambée de l'antisémitisme et de la
haine sur les réseaux sociaux et puis
comment comment l'éviter le chef de
l'État s'exprime ce soir pour appeler à
l'unité nationale bonsoir constance
legrip bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
député renaissance des haute scène vous
débattez ce soir avec Benjamin Lucas
votre collègue Europe Écologie Les ver
des iveline bonsoir Barbara Lefèvre
bienvenue vous êtes enseignante et
esséiste auteur en 2002 c'est important
de le rappeler des territoires perdus de
la République c'était des témoignages
d'enseignants vous vous étiez non pas
anonyme mais à visage ouvert et pas
d'autres enseignants déjà sur la montée
de l'antisémitisme et de l'islamisme
dans les collèges et les lycées c'était
dans la région parisienne on y reviendra
bonsoir François puponi bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes ancien maire de
sarcell vous vous avez vécu à l'été 2014
les heures dans votre ville
après une opération terrestre
israélienne sur Gaza on y reviendra
également François Xavier vous
connaissez cette région vous vous êtes
allé couvrir pour des reportages à la
fois les territoires palestiniens et
Israël n'hésitez pas à intervenir ou
même à interroger nos invités on va
commencer par faire le point sur ce qui
se passe en France depuis samedi il y
a-t-il oui ou non un véritable regain
d'antisémitisme Stéphane blakovski avec
son chrono tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir mir
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors que se
passe-t-il dans le pays depuis samedi ce
soir donc on parle du risque
d'importation en France de ce nouveau
conflit qui vient d'éclater entre le
Hamas et Israël d'emblé préciser que ça
ne concerne pas que la France hein sur
cette inquiétude vous voyez que pas mal
de pays occidentaux ont pris des mesures
préventives de sécurité justement par
rapport à ces risques faut dire que la
différence avec la France c'est que nous
sommes le pays d'Europe on est à la fois
avec la plus grosse communauté musulmane
et la plus grosse communauté juive donc
les risques sont peut-être
statistiquement plus important en tout
cas ce matin sur France interre Gérald
daranin donné les premiers chiffres avec
une hausse des actes antisémites plus
d'une centaine depuis le déclenchement
du conflit 24 interpellations et puis
encore un chiffre en hausse plus de 2000
signalements sur Faros qui vous savez
cette plateforme où on peut signaler les
contenus site en ligne
notamment les appels à la violence donc
l'inquiétude est d'autant plus légitime
que vous savez Israël s'apprête
vraisemblablement à lancer une opération
terrestre or en 2014 is avait déjà lancé
une opération terrestre contre Gaza et
les manifestations propolestinennes
organisées à l'époque avaient parfois
dégénéré vous l'avez dit notamment à
sarcell dont François pouoni était le
maire à l'époque donc c'est peut-être
aussi pour ça que géralde daranin
s'inquiète que des manifestations
propalestiniennes puissent mal tourner
et de manière générale pendant l'année
2014 les actes antisémites avaient
doublé en France je vous le rappelle
vous ne l'avez forcément pas oublié que
début 2015 un djihadiste a assassiné
quatre personnes dans un hyper marché
cachir porte de Vincen vous voyez le non
des victimes qui sont gravées sur la
plaque qui le r homage donc c'est pas
étonnant que 10 ans plus tard et bien on
s'inquiète à nouveau dans la perspective
d'une nouvelle opération terrestre
d'autant que ce qui a changé en disant
c'est que les réseaux sociaux ont pris
beaucoup plus d'importance notamment
dans le domaine de la de la de
l'information et c'est sans doute ce qui
inquiète le plus Gérald armanin on
l'écoute il y a quelque chose de latant
notamment cette haine sur internet je
pense qu'il faut il faut le souligner
parce que cette haine sur Internet c'est
celle qui est faitêtre par exemple
l'assassinat de Samuel Pat et il faut
voir que c'est désormais le djihadisme
d'atmosphère pour reprendre l'
expression islamiste qui permet le
passage à l'acte alors encore une fois
la France n'est pas la seule à
s'inquiéter voyez que au niveau européen
notre commissaire thry breton a pointé
du doigt à la fois le patron de X donc
l'ancien Twitter et le patron de
Facebook parce que les réseaux diffusent
des fausses informations des images qui
glorifient la violence alors
malheureusement on peut pas dire que mon
musk mon musk a été vraiment
impressionné voyez ça c'est la lettre de
mise en demeure de Thierry Breton euh la
réponse de Lon musk c'est euh j'ai
toujours pas compris de quoi il parle
euh j'ai dû rater un truc vous voyez
donc une forme de mépris adressé euh à
l'Europe et c'est d'illeurs le gros
problème de la France de l'Europe d'être
capable d'exercer si peu de contrôle en
définitive sur le contenu des réseaux
notamment dans une période comme
celle-ci parce que ça va permettre à des
régimes autoritaires d'utiliser les
réseaux sociaux justement pour tenter
ben de ce don on parle d'importer ce
conflit israelllo-palestinien en France
dans le but de déstabiliser les régimes
démocratiques en France ou en Europe on
écoute les explications de Hugo Micheron
qui est un chercheur à Science Po il y a
des maintenant même des pays qui des qui
sont des rivaux géopolitique je pense à
la Russie je pense à la Chine à la
Turquie aussi dans une certaine mesure
qui sont aujourd'hui capables de
diffuser des informations totalement
erronées ou totalement
contraire sur ce conflit là on voit les
les réseaux iraniens et russes très très
actifs pour pour en fait faire monter si
vous voulez la tension politique bon ben
voilà j'ai tenté de résumer un peu tous
les risques que représentait ortation du
conflit maintenant je vous laisse la
page j'espère que vous avez des
solutions simplement merci beaucoup
Stéphane une centaine donc d'ACT
antisémite depuis samedi matin constance
le gripe il y a eu un drone qui a
survolé un lieu cultuel Gérald dermanin
n'en a pas dit plus à ce stade on est
dans le risque d'importation ou pour
vous elle est elle est déjà là on est
dans un très fort risque d'importation
effectivement de de la tragédie qui qui
se déroule en en Israël et et et de
manière générale dans dans le proche
orient avec quand même d'ors et déjà
depuis samedi vous l'avez dit et redit
plus d'une centaine d'actes antisémites
commis sur le territoire de la
République je rappelle que l'année
dernière c'était très précisément sont
les chiffres du ministère de l'Intérieur
et du Service de Protection de la
communauté juive 436 actes antisémites
qui avaient été recensés de manière
générale tout le monde s'accordait à
dire que ces actes étaient très
largement sous-estimés puisque il y a
des signalements qui il sont pas fait il
y a des dépt de main courantes ou de
plaines c'est tout à fait impressionnant
on peut commencer à parler de
flamber des actes antisémites et donc
c'est extrêmement inquiétant déploiement
de force de sécurité instruction au
préfet instruction au parquet aussi pour
judiciariser pour ne rien laisser passer
et incitation aussi à ce que toutes
celles et tous ceux qui subissent des
injures des insultes des menaces de mort
quel que soit le terrain et cetera porte
pltete plainte porte plainte il
n'empêche que voilà on sent que
l'inquiétude est là la décision de Géral
daranin d'interdire a priori toutes les
manifestations propalestinennes c'est
dans une note adressée au préfet que
cette interdiction est formellement
explicité parce qu'elle constitue une
menace à l'ordre public est-ce que pour
vous Benjamin Lucas c'était la solution
dans le contexte actuel moi je veux dire
deux choses d'abord sur les actes
antisémites qui évidemment je les
condamne avec la la plus grande force
que ils sont d'une abjection totale et
qu'ils doivent être combatttu par la
puissance publique avec toute la force
de l'arsenal législatif pénal qui est le
nôre est condamné et qu'il faut
effectivement comme vous l'avez fait
Mame le grip
encourager de sécurité aussi éc les
synagogues tout ça vous saluez bien sûr
non mais tout tout ce qui permet
aujourd'hui de protéger les Juifs de
France tout ce qui permet aujourd'hui de
combattre fermement la diffusion de la
haine et de l'antisémitisme sur les
réseaux sociaux dans la société doit
être fait avec la plus grande fermeté
sur la question des manifestations moi
ma boussole dans un moment troublé dans
un moment où par ailleurs la classe
politique montre pas forcément un bon
exemple dans ces déclarations dans ses
récupérations et cetera mais je crois
qu'il faut rester sur la boussole du
droit et des principes que dit le droit
européen et national notamment la
l'article 10 de la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme c'est le principe
de la liberté de manifestation et
d'expression il dit aussi que ce
principe n'est pas absolu qu'une
manifestation qui contrevient à l'ordre
public peut-être interdite moi je crois
simplement qu'il ne faut pas interdire à
priori des mobilisations parce que si
vous avez des gens qui comme sans par
exemple à ce qu'a dit Dominique de
Villepin ce matin donc on viendra avec
moi qu'il n'est ni antisémite ni un fou
furieux c'est l'ancienistreci minist
d'affaires étrangère qui a dit notamment
que le droit à la légitime défense n'est
pas la vengeance si vous avez des gens
qui comme moi considèrent que il ne peut
pas y avoir de de punition collective à
l'égard des Palestiniens pour ce qu'a
commis le Hamas qui ne représente pas le
peuple palestinien si vous considérez
comme moi que le droit international
doit être respecté à Gaza et par l'État
israélien et qu' peut pas y avoir de
vengeance aveugle et et que vous voulez
l'exprimer dans une mobilisation alors
vous devez pouvoir le faire faire ce qui
doit être interdit ce sont les
manifestations de l'antisémitisme ce
sont les expressionsantisémitisme c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai une réserve très
forte voir une opposition avec le fait
que l'on interdise par principe toutes
les mobilisations je ne sais pas ce que
ça veut dire une mobilisation
proalestinienne par exemple moi je
souhaite me rendre à des des
mobilisations pour la paix qui viennent
en soutien évidemment d'abord aux
victimes aux victimes israéliennes
devant ces images horribles qui nous qui
nous laissent encore dans dans
lesffroids et qui viennent aussi en
appui au civils palestiniens qui sont de
fait les otages aujourd'hui du Hamas et
de polique c'est une entrave à la
liberté de manifester c'est ça la la
mesure prise par Gérald Darmanin c'est
une entrave à la liberté
constitutionnelle de manifest soit prise
de façon générale et indistincte et pour
moi un problème et moral et un problème
juridique en revanche en revanche je
termine on peut tout à fait quand un
risque je ne dis pas qu'il faut
autoriser toutes les manifestations
quand un risque à l'ordre public est
établi il y a des procédures qui sont
prévues pour cela le préfet peut
interdire et puis les justiciables
peuvent évidemment attaquer cette
décision c'est l'état de droit il faut
préserver l'état de droit dans les
moments dans lesquels nous Barbara
Lefèvre il faut dire aussi dans quel
contexte cette peut-être cette décision
a été prise il y a des appels notamment
d'un ancien responsable du
ramas à faire lever la rue arabe plutôt
en direction des des pays du
Moyen-Orient est-ce que ça peut
expliquer cette décision comment vous
vous la jugez c'est évident que pour
ceux qui défendent la cause
palestinienne il y aura le sentiment
d'un de poids de mesure certes chez
Géral Haran il y a quand même une
tendance ces derniers temps et
encourager sans doute par l'exécutif à
dissoudre euh beaucoup d'autres
mouvements euh on l'avait vu avec les
soulèvements de la terre qui a été
retoqué aussi par le tribunal donc on
sent bien quand même que chez Gérald
armanin et on peut comprendre
l'inquiétude concernant les troubles à
l'ordre public euh mais il y a quand
même une tendance à sortir très vite
cette cette arme euh soit de la
dissolution de la dissolution du NPA
alors que effffectivement les propos de
Monsieur Poutou peuvent tomber largement
et et les communiqués du NPA sous le
coup de la loi étant donné que c'est
quasiment de l'incitation euh à au
meurtrre euh mais euh pour autant je je
rejoins ce qui a été dit euh c'est quand
même compliqué d'interdire à priori par
ailleurs et néanmoins euh il y a la
théorie et nous sommes peut-être ici à
l'abri dans le domaine théorique mais
nous avons vu en France ce que ça
signifie souvent les manifestations
dites dites proalestiniennes parce que
euh elles ne défendent que très rarement
la cause palestinienne c'est-à-dire la
cause de la société civile la cause de
cette diaspora palestinienne
démocratique qui s'époumonne dans le
silence et l'ignorance absolue parce
qu'en réalité ces manifestations
tournent régulièrement à l'apologie du
terrorisme avec des drapeaux du Hamas
avec des appel à tuer les Juifs d'une
façon générale donc bien entendu il y a
la théorie et on est tous pour l'État de
droit mais en même temps il y a la
pratique et la France ayant été
particulièrement meurtrie et nous avons
eu aussi des manifestations dites
propalestiniennes et monsieur
piponi qui finissaiit devant des
synagogues avec des appels à tuer les
Juifs donc voilà il faut trouver cet
équilibre qui est difficile à alors
justement François pipony on va essayer
de se projeté enfin c'est plutôt
regarder dans le rétro presque 10 ans en
arrière vous étiez maire de Sarcel
qu'est-ce qui s'était passé ça c'est les
manifestations on va dire apaiser place
de la République c'est l'été juillet
2014 sauf qu'elles vont dégénérer dans
la capitale notamment devant une
synagogue et à sarcell expliquez-nous ce
que vous avez vécu
précisément une manifestation
propalestinienne qui est décidée
interdite par la
préfecture les manifestants viennent
quand même à la gare de sarcell le
dimanche le dimanche matin oui et puis
il décide de se rendre devant la
synagogue au cri de mort aux Juifs on va
vous brûler et ils mettent la ville à
sac ils rentrent dans un centre
commercial il ne cassent que les
commerces juifs et
caldéens ça a duré toute une après-midi
donc moi je connais pas beaucoup de
manifestation propalestinienne lorsqu'il
y a une
tension en Israël qui finissent pas au
cri de mort aux Juifs voilà celle-ci
celle-ci était interdite en les
interdisant toutes n'est pas en train de
prendre le risque qu'il y ait d'autres
Gaza 2014ou faut pas qu'on soit naïf les
raisons g les raisons de l'islam radical
sont actifs ils savent très bien qu'ils
attendent qu'une seule chose là c'est
que tsal rentre à Gaza et qu'il puisse
montrer des images en disant voilà ces
méchants israéliens ce qu'ils font aux
pauvres enfants palestiniens ils
excitent les plus fragiles de notre pays
qui sont capables de passer aux actes
derrière h la technique on la connaît
elle est éprouvée dans le monde entier
avec S R qui sont là pour véic mais qui
sont ces réseaux les réseaux de l'islam
radical qui sont les relais du ramas en
France par exemple t tous les la quasi
totalité des mouvements proalestiniens
de certains en train déclarer ils sont
là pour jeter de la haine je pas moi
organis manifestation pour dire la
Palestine a le droit de vivre très bien
mais ça finit vous avez vu hier à Lyon
Israël assassin Macron complice
manifestation qui a été interdite ou
interdite mais elles ont lieu quand même
elles ont lieu quand même pourquoi que
l'interdiction est quand même quelque
chose de n'a pas une efficacité pas
d'accord c'est là où je suis pas
d'accord parce que juridiquement
participer interdite c'est un délit donc
on peut ensuite poursuivre les condamné
et oui participer à une manifestation
qui est autorisée pénalement on peut pas
faire anémitisme est un délit mais moi
je moi je moi je suis pour que par
contre je vous le dis ma ma ma réserve
je vous l'ai dit sur l'interdiction des
manifestations mon hostilité elle est
sur le principe de l'État de droit en
revanche il est une évidence absolue que
tout acte antisémite qu'il soit dans une
manifestation ou ailleurs pe être
réprimé avec la plus grande sévérité
mais vous faites la dé vousord de faire
la démonstration dans ce qui s'est passé
à scell de de dramatique d'horrible en
2014 que l'interdiction n'avait pas
empêché les attaques et les actes
antisémites qui prouvve qu'on doit pas
être naï regarder ce qui fonctionne sauf
que si on autorise la manifestation à
lieu il y aura les les actes antisémites
il y aura les provocations antisémites
il y aura les insultes
antisémites rentrer dansation pour
interpeller quelqu'un qui criit mort aux
juif parce qu'on sa très bien donc la r
vous croyez pas que sielles sont
autorisé vont y venir aussi des gens qui
de bonne foi sans être hab
peut êtreï on peut quand même regarder
ce qui se passe depuis 25 an dans notre
pay majorité de la population dans notre
pays pardon mais JEE je regarde les
sondages l'immense majorité de la
population de notre pays compris
d'ailleurs le président de la République
le Gouvernement et je le salue a décidé
de défendre avec d'autres pays européens
un corridor humanitaire c'est une
position très très dans le pays peut des
gens qui ont envie de manifester leur
solidarité avec les
civitaire à Gaza pour qu'il puissent
passer en Égypte les f vous me citez une
manifestation propalestinienne en
période de crise qui n'a pas fini avec
des actes antisémites
je crois sauerreur quelques
manifestations qui ont eu lieu hier dans
des villes de taille moyenne qui
n'étaient pas interdites c'est là où on
aimerait comprendre effectivement
comment queles sont les règles pour
certaines villesres on est bien d'accord
et le ministre de l'Intérieur a
d'ailleurs dit ce matin encore que
c'était d'abord les organisateurs qui se
révisaient qu'il y avait des problèmes
on est d'accord moi il y a juste quelque
chose qui m'a non pas étonné mais mais
que je voulais relever juste après ce
qui s'est passé qui est évidemment
effroyable samedi il y a eu des
manifestation à New York proestinienne
et proisraélienne ces images ont ensuite
syncrétisé d'une certaine façon et sur
les réseaux sociaux elles ont transformé
New York quand il y a deux camps qui
s'affrontent on a vu dans d'autres
villes européennes notamment je pense à
Madrid des images où les propalestiniens
étaient dans les rues aussi
effectivement ce qui est un petit peu je
pense effrayant c'est qu'on résume
ensuite une ville et un pays à ces
quelques images en disant voilà quel est
le thermomètre social dans telle ville
et aujourd'hui on n'y est pas encore en
France je sais pas comment vous réagissz
vous quand vous voyez qu'effectivement
ça se cristallise de toutes part mais on
voit qu'effectivement en France ça n'est
pas encore le cas ou attendez c'est pas
encore le cas aujourd'hui en apparence
sans aucune innocence on est bien
d'accord voilà tout le monde sait très
bien que le jour où adzal va rentrer
dans
Gaza dans les heures les jours qui
viennent parce qu'il y a pas d'autres
solution pour l'État d'Israël je dis pas
que c'est bien je dis qu'on sait comment
ça va finir que les choses peuvent
basculer et que ces réseauxl n'attendent
que ça et et d'ailleurs le ramas quand
il a lorsqu'il a commis tous les actes
terroristes horribles qu'il a commis en
Israël le faisait pour ça pour essayer
qu'il une espèce d'embras international
voilà et que le monde musulman prenne
fait et caus pour lui parce que c'est ce
qu'il cherchait je voudrais nous ramener
à la France et au terrain vous avez
enseigner l'histoire géographie en
collège lycée Barbara LEF comment on
fait dans ces moments-là vous avez des
des anciens collègues qui vous racontent
depuis 5 jours comment comment les
élèves réagissent comment les
professeurs affrontent ce moment-là avec
eux qu'est-ce qu'ils redoute je suis de
nouveau en poste mais pour autant voilà
mais dans l'Académie de versaill mais je
ne je n'observe pas euh de manifestation
dans le cadre de ce qui peut se passer
dans les dans les classes néanmoins
lundi euh c'est l'hommage à Samuel Patti
euh qui se déroulera dans certains
établissements normalement dans tous
mais euh certains établissements donc et
justement vous interroger tout à l'heure
sur la question des réseaux mais je
rappellerai quand même que nombre de ces
manifestations dites propalestiniennes
étaient organisées ou co-organisées par
certains collectifs et notamment le
collectif cher Yassine et ce collectif
cher Yassine il était dirigé fondé même
par euh monsieur sifrioui qui est un des
acteurs et un des pivots même de la la
la C voilà il va être jugé de la cabale
contre collègue contre Samuel Paty et
probablement d'ailleurs si Samuel Patti
a été assassiné dans ses conditions
atroce il il en prend une immense
responsabilité ce collectif cheer
Yassine du nom quand même du fondateur
du ramas pendant des années il a vécu
tranquillement monsieur Darmanin l'a
dissou lui aussi mais enfin il l'a
dissou après combien d'années de
nuisance et il était dans toutes les
manifestations propalestiniennes donc
ces réseaux on les connaît c'est bien
sûr ces réseaux djihadistes mais c'est
aussi derrière les réseaux fréristes
bien sûr et là aussi on a un vrai
problème en France parce que je ne veux
pas parler du cas israélien quand on
entend on va détruire et exterminer le
le Hamas et le Hamas va disparaître non
le Hamas ne disparaîtra pas puisque
l'idéologie qui le nourrit qui nourrit
le Hezbollah qui nourrit les Frères
musulmans qui nourrit certains partis en
France comme certains groupes qui sont
les interlocuteurs hélas de nos de nos
élus euh et bien ça cette idéologie là
elle ne disparaîtra pas et elle
disparaîtra d'autant moins que nous
avons une population une nouvelle
génération qui est extrêmement sensible
sur les réseaux sociaux à toute forme de
discours comploti et là on a un vrai
problème parce que justement ces réseaux
sociaux sont le lieu de la diffusion de
cette propagande ou et ça change tout
d'avoir les réseaux sociaux par rapport
eu il y a 10 ans 2014 justement dans
certains quartiers il y a des
influenceur qui s'adresse aux Français
d'origine musulmane pour appeler au
calme c'est le cas de ben on va
l'écouter sur TikTok et puis on va
trouvé par Skype juste après regardez
alors oui il y a de la justice oui on ne
parle pas des enfants et des femmes
tuées en Palestine dans les médias vous
avez tout à fait le droit de ne pas être
d'accord avec la politique israélienne
mais les Juifs de France même si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec eux n'ont
strictement rien à voir avec tout cela
bonsoir ben vous êtes avec nous bonsoir
merci d'être là alors qu'est-ce que vous
voyez précisément sur les réseau RX
sociaux depuis l'attaque terroriste du
ramas sur les réseaux sociaux je vois
tout ce que je ne vois pas dans les
médias c'est-à-dire c'est des gens qui
sont en colère mais qui ne sont pas
représentés ou bien des gens qui sont
représentés par un seul imam qui
s'exprime super mal qui est l'Imam
chalgoumi et d'autres imams qui toute
l'année font des vidéos qui ne
s'expriment plus du tout depuis depuis
ce conflit alors c'est on est un peu
comment vous dire
braqué les gens ont peur de dire ce
qu'ils pensent mais je pense que si les
gens disent ce qu'ils pensent ça
apaisera les tensions vous avez
l'impression que le combat que vous
menez pour le vivre ensemble pour
l'unité nationale pour garder le
dialogue le droit de critiquer aussi
évidemment Israël et son gouvernement
vous le menez un peu seul sur les
réseaux ou
pas alors non j'ai j'ai énormément de
soutien euh j'ai des gens c'est sûr que
même moi je me fais quelquefois agresser
dans les commentaires et cetera c'est
une réalité mais par contre il faut
absolument que les gens puissent
s'exprimer moi ce que j'ai remarqué
c'est que les gens n'arrivent pas à ils
ont l'impression d'être en fait
et ils regardent toute la journée les
médias on ne parle jamais des des
Palestiniens qui sont morts on a aucune
image mais par contre dans les réseaux
on a énormément d'images de Gaza on a
énormément d'images et les gens sont
braqués et je vous dis ils ont besoin de
s'exprimer et s'ils s'expriment pas le
risque c'est qu'il se soit frustré et
qu'il se radicalise donc pour vous la
suppression de contenu les lois sur le
numériques qui sont à la fois négociés
ici enfin à Bruxelles et et ici même à
l'Assemblée en ce moment font pas
forcément dans dans le bon sens où il
faut absolument faire en sorte que tous
les contenus illicites
disparaissent alors oui les les contenus
qui vont au-delà du raisonnable faudrait
que ces contenus là disparaissent ça
c'est sûr mais par contre il y a des
gens qui sont tout à fait modérés et les
réseaux sociaux quelquefois les brident
et cetera alors qu'il ne faudrait pas il
faudrait que les gens puissent
s'exprimer librement et puis je pense
qu'on peut arriver à et surtout avec des
médiateurs et qu'on et qu'on pourra
justement avancer comme ça mais en
bridant les gens je vous dis ça va créer
de la frustration et les gens vont vont
exploser au bout d'un moment et et c'est
très dangereux pour le pays merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec nous
dans dans cette émission donner juste
une petite précision parce que moi je
travaille pour TF1 et samedi et dimanche
évidemment on avait un flot incessant
d'image qui était insoutenable
évidemment bien
entendu on a choisi de ne pas les
diffuser pour cell évidemment du Hamas
on écrivait images de propagande de la
première à la dernière seconde où on
utilisait ces images mais il est
évidemment important de rappeler que
c'est pas Brid idée que de sélectionner
c'est notre boulot de journaliste de
sélectionner les images que l'on estime
soutenables et que l'on estime pas
soutenable et par ailleurs aussi c'est
important de rappeler que les
journalistes occidentaux pour
l'écrasante majorité sauf ceux qui
étaient déjà présents à Gaza dans le
cadre d'agence de presse comme la BBC ou
la FP pour les autres ils ne peuvent pas
rentrer à Gaza d'où évidemment le
déséquilibre en terme d'image qui n'est
pas évidemment je compte pas les points
en disant ça c'est juste ben vous voulez
réagir pour répondre à François Xavier
ménage rapidement et puis je vous passe
la parpr juste dire qu'il faut dans les
médias j'ai l'impression qu'on a mis le
Hamas un peu dans le lot des
Palestiniens juste bien dissocié on sait
tous que le Hamas est une organisation
terroriste ça il y a pas de doute
là-dessus les gens veulent s'exprimer
sur les les les familles les femmes et
les enfants qui meurent pas contre le
Hamas le Hamas on est tous contre on
devrait être tous contre voilà c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire merci Merci
à VOUS François puponi le djihadisme
d'atmosphère c'est une expression de
Gill kpel le chercheur la sciencep
aujourd'hui à l'École normale sur sur le
Moyen-Orient euh on peut le on peut le
combattre aujourd'hui s'il existe vous
avez vécu 2014 très compliqué très
compliqué parce que c'est une idéologie
qui se qui s'installe dans des quartiers
dans des villes et qui s'attaquent au
plus fragiles de ces quartiers qui sont
souvent les plus dstructurés parce que
ceux qui sont à la base d'ologie ils
passent pas à l'acte eu hein son assez
intelligent pour aller manipuler et donc
c'est une espèce de de bombe à
fragmentation qui peut péter à n'importe
quel moment parce que on a engrainé un
certain nombre d'individus qui peuvent
passer à l'acte et c'est ça qui est
terrible il y a des réseaux organisés
qui font des attentats on l'a connu en
France et puis maintenant les individus
qu'on lâche dans la nature comme ça
qu'on chauffe un peu et les réseaux
sociaux ils participent le grandement et
qui sont capables de croiser un juif
dans la rue et de lui taper dessus voir
pire ça malheureusement ça existe ça ve
dire que pour les élus terrain qui
essayent en ce moment dans les quartiers
populaires de s'appuyer sur les
associations de s'appuyer sur les
enseignants et sur ses réseaux et sur
ses et ben oui sur ces réseaux sociaux
aussi ch sur ces réaux ça ça devient
maintenant le nouveau terrain pour
essayer de d'éviter le pire non bon ce
serait un débat de de longues heures sur
comment on combat vous avez raison c'est
un c'est c'est un combat compliqué vous
avez vu la réaction d'Éon musk bon oui
non mais voilà et on est on est je crois
dans toutes les périodes de crise et
particulièrment de crise internationale
sur sur un terraro qui est effectivement
très propice à tout les euh toutes les
organisations de haine les organisations
terroristes et cetera elle elle
recrutent elle prospère dans les moment
de de tension de difficulté de crise et
donc je crois que notre responsabilité à
nous d'élu en étant lucide sur le fait
que ce sont des combats qui sont longs
qui ne sont jamais gagnés d'avance c'est
aussi de remettre ça fait un peu
angélique de le dire comme ça mais mais
de remettre les valeurs de la République
partout c'est de remettre des services
publics de remettre de redonner de la
force à l'école de redonner de la force
à nos enseignantes à nos enseignants qui
sont mais qui sont le premier Bouclier
civique citoyens pour apprendre et je le
dis alors qu'on va alors qu'on va
commémorer la mémoire de de de Samuel
paatti lundi vous vous l'avez rappelé on
doit euh enfin enfin et on avait la la
discussion aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
la nicheren qui diffusait sa haine
contre les quartiers populaires on doit
enfin euh donner une perspective aux
habitants et aux habitants des quartiers
populaires c'est-à-dire que la devise
républicaine liberté égalité fraternité
doit vouloir dire quelque chose dans la
vie quotidienne de ces de ces jeunes
mais quand vous êtes je n'excuse pas
j'explique encore une fois parce que
expliquer n'est pas excuser quand vous
êtes victimes des discriminations quand
vous êtes victime des contrôles
discriminatoires quand vous êtes
victimes de violence policièrees quand
vous êtes victime du CH age évidemment
que ça ça n'excuse jamais rien mais ça
explique qu'il y a un terro plus
favorable ensuite pour d'autres idées
d'autres idéologie que l'idée
républicaine et que l'idée que nous
faisons communauté nationale et c'est ça
que nous dem justement on va terminer
sur ce point communauté nationale et on
fera un dernier tour de table complet
c'est ce qui essaie de créer cette union
nationale le chef de l'État qui
s'exprime ce soir en réunissant un peu
plus tôt dans la journée tous les chefs
de parti comme il l'avait fait à
Saint-Denis appeler au calme réunir la
nation est-ce possible regarde les
réaction elles ont été rassemblé par ma
fr chef de parti unanime sur la
libération des otages on trouvit
important d'avoir ce temps d'échange
entre entre partis Politi animé organisé
par le Président de la République qui
permettent de poser les arguments sur la
table d'avoir évidemment une pensée
urgentes et des besoins d'action urg sur
la libération des otages à gauche
Olivier for a tenu à dire àemu ron que
le soutien à Israël ne devait pas être
inconditionnel nous avons là en
fait demander au chef de l'État de ne
pas aligner la France sur le
gouvernement israélien de garder une
parole de s'exprimer à la fois en
direction du monde arabe et en direction
des Israéliens et de continuer à
promouvoir une parole qui soit une
parole de Pai chez les républicains
éicti a une nouvelle fois regretté le
maintien de l'aide au ement fourni par
la France et par l'Union européenne à la
Palestine je le dis très clairement j'ai
été déçu par le maintien de cette aide
même si le président l' sorti de
conditions de contrôle plus exigeantes
mais cette aide au développement dont je
demande aujourd'hui la suspension à tout
le moins tant que les otages ne sont pas
libérés sera maintenu je le regrette le
patron des républicains a également
regretté la présence de la France
insoumise à cette réunion ce qui a
provoqué la colère d'Emmanuel Bompard je
trouve indigne de profiter de cette
situation pour essayer de mener des
petites batailles politiciennes comme
l'a dit l'ancien ministre des Affaires
étrangères Dominique de Villepin ce
matin à la télé ça me dégoûte bah je
reprends ces mots moi aussi ça me
dégoûte constance legrip cette union
nationale dans le moment qu'on traverse
voilà n'est pas possible manifestement
non mais il faut savoir ce que on
appelle union nationale on va pas créer
demain matin un gouvernement d'union
nationale he ça a une certaine
signification les termes d'union
nationale de soutien de tous les chefs
de partis un esprit de concorde que l'on
essaie de faire souffler en France je
pense que c'est absolument essentiel et
c'est la responsabilité de chacun et
chacune dans les grandes familles
politiques parce que effectivement le
risque
d'impimportation des de la tragédie dans
notre pays le risque de voir des
quartiers
entier partir à la dérive de voir des
manifestations se déployer de manière
extrêmement violente de voir les
discours de haine aller en s'amplifiant
sur les réseaux sociaux tout cela doit
nous amener à être chacun et chacune
d'entre nous les grandes familles
politiques dans un devoir de
responsabilité et d'appel quand même à
de la raison et de la la Concorde mais
sans naïveté sans naïveté le terrorisme
islamiste qui s'en est pris à Israël
samedi matin c'est celui qui s'en prend
à nous aussi c'est le même et le combat
d'Israël contre le terrorisme islamiste
c'est le nôtre donc sans naïveté il faut
être les yeux grands ouverts sur les
réalités du monde les bouleversements
géopolitiques qui sont à l'èvre quand
même depuis pas mal de temps avec
maintenant des bouleversements qui vont
aller crchendo le jeu d'un certain
nombre de grandes puissances régionales
et la faculté d'un certain nombre de de
proxis de la République islamique d'Iran
ou d'autres
à poursuivre et amplifier le travail de
de destruction et de désagrégation de
nos sociétés démocratiques donc donc le
chef deétat qui va prendre la parole
d'un minute à l'autre vous vous attendez
vous en attendez quoi mais il faut une
unité demtion unité deation mais
président la République doit être pour
moi quand j'entends monsieur choti je me
dis qu'ils enterrent Jacques cherac une
deuxiè fois les républains il doit être
fidèle à ce qui est la parole de la
France je dis moi je soutiens l'unité
elle se elle se décrète pas l'unité elle
se construit sur des propositions quand
la France réclame avec d'autres pays un
corridor humanitaire quand la ministre
affffaires étrangères Catherine Colona
dit qu'il faudra une solution à deux
états et rappelle le droit international
je je je je soutiens il y a pu avoir des
attermement dans dans le début mais je
je suis prêt à les soutenir en revanche
il peut pas y avoir d'unité nationale
avec euh Madame Le Pen qui resserre sa
sa sa sauce de de choc des civilisations
et ces théories fumeuses qui visent à la
guerre civile en France ailleurs dans le
monde pas d'unité nationale françisis
qui ne peut pas dire que le ramas est
terroriste mal manif moi je moi je l'ai
dit euh moi je l'ai dit après il y a
condamnation pour moi unanime de la
classe politique française tout le monde
a condamné euh ici à l'Assemblée
nationale les actes les actes
terroristes duas maintenant je crois
vraiment que la question de la Concorde
républicaine elle dépend beaucoup du
chef de l'État et du président de la
République qui doit ce soirouver les
mots pere la France portera une parole
de paix une
parole interationale
comme parifiant qui au jour
d'aujourd'hui sont pas
très par que il y a eu le 11 septembre
aux
États-Unis qui a reproché aux Américains
de faire ce qu'ils ont fait après nous
nous quand nous étions parti socialiste
gu
on était contre la Guer
IR est-ce que je peux finir il y a eu
des attentats en France François
Hollande a dit j'ai donné l'ordre au
soldat français de tuer les djihadistes
là où on les trouv c'était dans le
bouquin entendu
mais quand il a fait la dé de
nationance la France s'est vengée la
France s'est vengée et personne a dit
c'est scandaleux et là Israël dit moi je
vais me
venger
Israël la question la question nous on s
Veng pas le sujet du débat vous voulez
parleration du vous parlez de la
léleementoit
Inter parce que daesh nous avait tué sur
le sol
national nous n'avons pas attaqué un
pays des civils de cette façon opération
terrestre elle a pas encore eu lieu donc
on vous réinvitera pour débattre le
moment venu Barbara le fa qu'est-ce que
vous craignez le plus pour notre pays
vous aurez le mot de la fin VI ce que je
crains le plus c'est qu'on continue avec
les discours lénifiants et je crois tout
à fait à votre sincérité lorsque vous
nous avez parlé des valeurs de la
République l'école doit transmettre les
valeurs de la République j'igne depuis
j'enseigne depuis 20 ans ça fait 20 ans
que j'entends ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous tout comme tout à
l'heure la théorie maintenant la
pratique moi je vais vous dire ce qu'on
doit d'abord enseigner aux élèves pour
que justement il ne soit plus prisonnier
de la boue qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'on ne peut rien contre
le cerveau à mon avis pas très net de
Monsieur musk et ni d'ailleurs celui de
Monsieur Zuckerberg qui ne voudront
jamais régler leurs réseaux sociaux ni
de toute la boue qui s déverse en terme
de propagande donc ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que avant de parler de valeur de
la République à l'école qu'on transmette
de l'instruction des connaissances en
histoire en philosophie qu'on arrête de
discréditer un certain nombre de
disciplines la littérature tout ce qui
fait qu' que quelqu'un pense par
lui-même et non plus pense par les
algorithmes et quand on aura déjà oui
mais c'est une grosse rééducation temp
sur cette note de consensus vous serez
tous d'accord
làdus beauoup on s'arrête là vous restez
avec moi François Xavier ménage dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pr nous
affranchis ce soir le grand reporter
Vincent eug voulait revenir évidemment
sur ces attaques terroristes pour lui
éradiquer le ramasse Mission Impossible
philosophe Nathan de vert quand les mots
manquent devant l'horreur et puis de
quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir Marco
vomier dans Bourbon express et ben ce
soir je vais vous parler d'un piège
politique tendu par le rassemblement
national je vous explique tout dans
quelques minutes mais d'abord on va se
plonger dans cette France qui craque
celle que vous avez documenté pendant 5
ans de reportage François Xavier ménage
c'est un une invitation signé Baptiste
gargy Chartier on en parle tous les deux
juste après François Xavi ménage si on
vous invite c'est parce que vous avez
sillonné une France au bord de la crise
sociale et ça craque titre de votre
dernier livre qui nous plonge dans des
témoignages saisissant d'une France qui
galère donc c'est le principe même de ce
bouquin expliquer comment les choses se
passent en 2023 jusqu'à quel point
certains luttent très différemment de
soi-même et je pense que cet éclatement
ce côté totalement fragmenté du pays il
faut le raconter François Xav ménage
vous êtes journaliste grand reporter
ayant couvert des terrains en zone de
guerre déjà quatre ouvrages au compteur
dont celui sur la catastrophe à
Fukushima reste le plus marquant mais
cette fois vous vous glissez dans
l'habit du porte-parole de ces Français
qui ne s'expriment jamais 5 an
d'enquête je donne la parole à des gens
qui sont tous dans l'action qui tous
essayent de s'en sortir qui tous sont
sur le point de craquer mais aucun ne
craque vraiment et je pense que c'est
important de montrer ce mélange
d'optimisme et de pessimisme donc c'est
pas un enfer on est dans un purgatoire
votre livre dresse le portrait d'une
France
éclatée un enchaînement histoire de vie
que vous nous racontez autour d'une
multitude de thèmes pouvoir d'achat
santé éducation logement transport tout
y passe dans votre ligne de mire ces
territoire oublié fracturé et ces
Français qui se sentent parfois délaissé
j'ai appelé pour prendre rendez-vous on
m'a dit pas avant mercredi et en forçant
j'ai pu avoir un rendez-vous et c'est
tout le temps comme ça on va déménager
d'Orb on pensait retourner dans la
vallée de Vilet parce qu'on sait que
là-bas il y a une maison médicale après
ça fait peur quand même parce qu'on se
dit qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir s'il y a
pas de médecin vous évoquez alors un
décalage 5 ans pour tenter de mieux
comprendre la France alors François
Xavier ménage face au constat que vous
faites est-il trop tard selon vous pour
la
réparer réponse je suis pas politique je
pense queidout non tout n'est pas foutu
absolument pas ça craque mais tout le
monde en tout cas tous ceux que
j'interroge il y en a quand même des
centaines dans ce livre qui qui tous
essaye alors avec des sparadras avec des
pensements ça se décolle c'est pas c'est
jamais parfait mais je vois beaucoup de
personnes qui tentent souvent localement
d'essayer de trouver des solutions ils
le font souvent dans la douleur mais
mais c'est ça aussi qu'il faut souligner
il tienent un peu les murs mais ils ont
quand même encore quelques raisons
d'espérer alors vous décrivez une France
le sujet le montrait éclaté fragmenté où
plus personne ne se comprend ni son
voisin ni encore plus celui qui vit dans
la ville d'à côté depuis quand on est
paumé comme ça depuis quand le pays
semble se méconnaître lui-même comme
vous l'écrivez alors j'ai évidemment pas
la réponse ce qui est juste certain
c'est que tout s'accélère je crois que
et on l'a entendu tout à l'heure dans
dans le cadre du débat la France elle va
plus vite que nous elle se transforme
plus vite que nous et donc on est
forcément paomé mais moi le premier en
tant que citoyen parfois même en tant
que reporter je suis tout à fait honnête
avec vous j'arrive à 9h du Matth sur
certaines thématiques que j'ai pas
couvert depuis un certain temps ou dans
des territoires où j'étais pas allé et
je suis paumé donc franchement je me
mets au même niveau que les autres mais
je pense que si on veut comprendre où on
habite nous il faut qu'on comprenne un
peu plus où habitent les Fran français
il y a la France des opinions on entend
ceux qui tapent du point sur la table
qui disent c'est la France c'est comme
si la France c'est comme ça je pense
qu'il faut peut-être d'abord comprendre
dans quelles condition vivent nos
voisins ceux qui habitent dans la ville
d'à côté jusqu'à quel point c'est
compliqué pour eux et et le faire en
thématisant ce que je fais dans le livre
logement santé insécurité vivre ensemble
qui est vraiment un mot clé dans dans ce
livre essayons de comprendre des
exemples particuliers qui sont pas
hasard on va partir de Grini dans les
sones 30000 habitants c'est la ville la
plus pauvre de France chômage insécurité
des mississions de l'État et pour
couronner le tableau c'est votre premier
chapitre pas de supermarché à l'heure où
les Français sont au centimes près
comment c'est possible c'est vrai que on
se dit tout le temps l'inflation c'est
très très compliqué pour les français
pour savoir quel produit ils vont
pouvoir prendre quand ils vont à la
caisse et bien là à Grini la question se
pose pas parce qu'il y a pas de
supermarché alors que c'est probablement
la ville qui en aurait le plus besoin
puisque c'est la ville la plus pauvre de
France et donc vous avez 30000 habitants
qui sont obligés d'aller faire leur
course à côté ce que je raconte dans ce
livre c'est que vous avez un élu le
maire de Grini qui se bat avec ses armes
pour essayer de faire venir des
supermarchés mais que quand un
supermarché dit je suis prêt à venir
voilà été élu meilleur maire du monde he
il y a pas très longtemps il s'en
venteent pas mais on peut le faire pour
lui et bien quand des supermarchés
disent et c'est arrivé quelque fois moi
je suis prêt à venir vous avez ensuite
des batailles judiciaires parce que les
supermarchés a tour disent non ça va
nous faire baisser notre chiffre
d'affaires et donc c'est cette bataille
là politique elle est éminemment
politique cette bataille qu'il faut
documenter il faut raconter ça se passe
à 20 km de Paris donc on évoque souvent
une France la France des grandes villes
et la France périérique mais en fait la
périphérie elle est parfois à l'autre
bout de la rue et je pense que c'est ça
aussi cette France qui avance très vite
avec les gagnants les perdants qui sont
pas forcément ceux que l'on croit et le
boulot des reporters c'est justement de
documenter cela ce qui est passionnant
dans le livre c'est de montrer le
système D de de tout le monde finalement
pour reprendre l'exemple de de l'élu
Philippe rioot raconte que au moment des
émeutes d'urbaines en juin dernier et
bien avec les parents d'élèves il était
dans les écoles pour essayer d'empêcher
les les sacages ou les éventuels dit
c'est aussi ça cette France qui se bat
elle fait tout bien au-delà d'une
mission de l'élu elle peut prendre des
des boulots des missions qui qui ne lui
appartiennent pas du tout et ce qui est
fascinant c'est que bien souvent ces
élus notamment les élus mais les
citoyens aussi dans leur ensemble il
lève pas le doigt pour dire venez voir
ce que je fais déjà c'est important
journalistiquement d'aller voir ceux qui
ne lèvent pas le doigt pour dire e j'ai
des choses à dire et effectivement aussi
c'est vrai que c'est ce que j'appelle le
syndrome de la double casquette ce sont
des maires des élus qui se trans
soirement pompiste pour mettre en place
une station essence quitte à ce qu'il y
ait un million d'euros d'investi dans
une petite commune pour qu'elle ne meure
pas et le maire et ben il passe de son
bureau à sa station essence ce sont des
élus qui vont effectivement réparer
parfois des écoles juste avant la
rentrée des classes parce qu'il y a
paser un détective ou embaucher un
détective ça c'est probablement un des
faits qui moi m'a le plus marqué
c'est-à-dire que dans une ville de
Bretagne qui symbolise comme tant
d'autres le désert médical et bien à
force de ne pas trouver de médecin de
campagne vous avez un élu qui a dit on
va va appel un détective le détective du
coin et lui peut-être qu'il arrivera à
trouver un médecin de campagne il a
réussi ça a coûté 2000 € et c'est ça qui
est intéressant et qui est symbolique il
y a eu un vote démocratique d'une
certaine façon c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
des lignes budgétaires qui ont été
choisies par le conseil municipal qui a
dit ok on va faire appel à un détective
privé je pense que ça dit beaucoup de
choses que cette France de la
débrouillardise de 2023 sans que ce soit
forcément heureux hein parce que je
pense que les premiers acteurs sont
justement ceux qui disent au tout début
on aurait voulu faire autrement bien sûr
com BR oui alors on voit ce qui se
débrouille ce qui se démènne mais on
voit aussi tous ceux qui raccrochent et
ça vous en parlez beaucoup de tous ces
élus qui n'en peuvent plus on a beaucoup
parlé de Saint-Brévin ce maire qui a
menacé de mort après sa volonté
d'installer un un un camp de de réfugi à
du renoncer un camp de migrant euh c'est
c'est un phénomène que vous arrivez à
mesurer à partir de de cette enquête en
gros sur une proportion de de
pourcentage on pourrait dire qu'on en
est où alors bah on va être très très
scientifique le morbillant qui est pas
le département le plus en crise de
France depuis les dernières élections
c'est scientifique ça a été compté par
l'Association des maires de France
départementale vous avez un taux de
démission des élus et des maires de
l'ordre de 15 % c'est-à-dire si on
compare avec le secteur privé 5 fois
plus que le secteur privé ça c'est les
conséquences j'en parle dans le livre je
pense que c'est saisissant de comprendre
et de prendre la mesure de cela des
causes c'est quoi c'est parfois des
menaces de mort parce que les élus ne
font pas assez c'est en tout cas ce
qu'ils disent c'est aussi une
bureaucratie qui prend une telle place
qu'elle devient démurgique et que il
n'arrive plus à faire face à cela et
c'est aussi une quête de sens et des
élus qui disent je ne sais plus où est à
la fois mon rôle et à la fois ce que je
peux apporter ce qu'on attend de moi ce
qui montre aussi une désorientation qui
est quand même un petit peu effrayante
mais c'est important d'entendre leur mot
c'est important de comprendre ce quoti
le ma pourtant c'estette dernière élu
préféré des Français sur la santé les
pages sont absolument édifiantes il y a
6 millions de Français qui n'ont pas de
généraliste vous avez rencontré ces
médecins en burnout qui font des heures
de dingue et qui décident finalement de
se déconventionner est-ce que vous les
comprenez il sortent de la Sécu ils sont
montrés du doigt parce que forcément
c'est une médecine de riche quand on
n'est plus remboursé vous les comprenez
alors est-ce que je les comprends c'est
pas à moi de vous dire en revanche
est-ce que je peux l'expliquer oui on a
suivi le CTI
d'un médecin qui justement avait fait
trop de Burnout et qui par ailleurs
trouvait que sa santé était en jeu et
qui a arrêté qui a dit je vais me mettre
secteur 3 le secteur 3 ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous n'avez plus du
tout de remboursement auprès de la
Sécurité sociale et même de votre mutuel
si vous allez voir ce médecin ça se
passe à newor juste à côté de newor
capitale de France des mutuels c'est
quand même tristement ironique et bien
qui va voir ce médecin et c'est ce que
je raconte dans le livre ce sont
beaucoup de patients de la classe
moyenne qui me disent on va faire des
sacrifices on va dépenser 60 ou 50 €
sans avoir le moindre centime de
rembourser mais d'abord on n' pas le
choix parce qu'on fait partie de ces 6
millions de Français qui n'arrivont pas
à trouver de médecin généraliste et par
ailleurs on le fait aussi parce que et
ben on va renier sur d'autres dépenses
mais ça nous semble important et et donc
c'est même pas une médecine de riche
c'est une médecine pour ceux qui sont
paumés qui n'ont plus de médecin qui
disent on va faire comme ça parce qu'on
a pas le choix donc il y a la
débrouillardise mais il y a aussi ce mur
qui est pris dans la gueule de beaucoup
de Français qui disent on n' pas le
choix il y a pas la voie a la voie B la
voie C et on n pas menu au resto chinois
ont choisi son son menu c'est il y a pas
le choix par aussi beaucoup des
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui sont sous le
poids des injonctions contradictoires la
pénurie de recrutement de de soignants
et et et la nécessité de de garder les
les services ouverts vous parlez des
infirmières scolaires on en a un peu
parler avec les les drames du
harcèlement et les suicides récents
Samia qui veille sur 1300 élèves sur
quatre établissements différents et qui
affrontent cette cette montée de
violence dans dans ses établissements
alors d'abord elle est intéressante pour
deux points Samia d'abord parce qu'elle
reflète des chiffres tout à fait
nationaux c'està-dire qu'une infirmière
scolaire en général a entre 1000 et 1600
élèves à gérer elle jongle d'un
établissement à l'autre et ce qui est
assez effrayant c'est que depuis le
confinement Samia dit comme beaucoup de
de ses conceurs qu'il y a effectivement
un décrochage cololaire un décrochage
social de la part de certains et qui
n'arrive pas à se relever et elle donne
le détail glaçant d'un enfant chez qui
il y a beaucoup de problèmes et on va
évidemment garder cet anonymat mais cet
enfant qui est pas encore en âge d'aller
au collège va faire une tentative de
suicide elle va l'apprendre dans la
bouche de cet enfant qui ne l'avait pas
dit à ses parents et ensuite elle
représente quand même le le tissu social
cette infirmière elle va essayer de
trouver un rendez-vous chez un psy pour
que ce petit garçon soit pris en charge
pour que ses parents rentrent également
dans cette boucle et elle met des mois
et des mois et des mois pour obtenir un
rendez-vous auprès d'un psychologue qui
évidemment est remboursé par la Sécurité
Sociale et ça montre là encore des
défaillances dans un état qui tente
beaucoup de choses évidemment c'est pas
simple d'être politique aujourd'hui et
et de et de faire partir même si le lien
entre l'État et les citoyens vous le
montrez bien et c'est complètement
délité vous montrez aussi que c'est
l'indifférence complète au discours
politique on pourrait parler du logement
des jeunes l'évaporation qui essayent de
joindre les debouts les banques
alimentaires il y a énormément
d'exemples tout ça c'est ma dernière
question d'un mot fait le jeu de Marine
Le Pen ou c'est trop facile de penser ça
je pense que c'est trop facile de de de
penser ça moi j'ai suivi la dernière
campagne présidentielle en suivant tous
les candidats pour des documentaires
pour TF1 et ce qui me marquait c'est que
évidemment il y a un discours politique
mais mais il y a même plus un divorce
c'est-à-dire pour beaucoup de Français
j'employais le mot à l'instant
d'évaporation de gazéification
c'est-à-dire que c'est comme si c'était
c'est le mot qui moi en tout cas me
marque dans la pièce d'à côté et que ça
n'était plus dans le champ de vision de
beaucoup de Français c'est-à-dire que il
y a quelques années on aurait pu dire
oui c'est les extrême qui vont gagner je
ne sais pas aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment que pour beaucoup de Français
sans généraliser surtout sans faire de
populisme la politique est effectivement
dans la pièce d'à côté ce qui dit
beaucoup de choses sur les les fractures
sociétal différence générale merci
beaucoup François Xavi ménage ça craque
travail argent logement santé éducation
vivre ensemble un reporter de guerre
dans une France explosive c'est-à-dire
chez Robert LAF ça ferait un bon
documentaire un bon reportage parce
qu'on a envie de de voir les visages de
tous ceux que vous décrivez vous restez
avec moi c'est l'heure des partie prè
nos affranchis on les accueille tout de
suite il v vous faire réagir et
bienvenue Nathan de vert notre
philosophe dans sa vous regarde le grand
reporter Vincent eugu tous les deux à
votre manière ce soir vous vouliez
revenir sur les attaques terroristes du
ramas contre Israël installez-vous on
commence comme chaque soir par Bourbon
Express bien sûr Marco Pomier vous nous
racontez l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée bonsoir bonsoir Myriam ce
soir je vous raconte l'histoire d'un
piège politique qui n'avait presque
aucune chance d'aboutir piège tendu par
le rassemblement national à la majorité
et à la gauche notamment avec une
proposition loi pourtant consensuelle
mieux m prendre en charge les femmes
atteintes d'endométriose les règles
douloureuses touchent une femme sur 10
en France c'était l'un des se textes
présenté aujourd'hui par le
rassemblement national pour sa journée
d'initiative parlementaire mais ce midi
après 3h de débat et le rejet de deux
article clé le député Emmanuel tacher de
la Pagerie jette
l'éponge ce texte qui pouvait susciter
un un espoir pour les femmes atteintes
d'endométriose et désormais vide je
souhaite donc plus que nous continuons à
à l'étudier pour le reste je suis député
mais je suis surtout dépité merci dépité
avec son texte le député eren entendait
accorder aux femmes atteintes
d'endométriose un statut d'affection
longue durée pour une prise en charge à
100 % des frais de santé permettre aussi
aux femmes qui le souhaitent et bien de
bénéficier d'un statut de travailleuse
handicapé peu importe hors de question
pour la majorité et la gauche et bien de
rompre le cordon sanitaire avec le
groupe de Marine Le Pen ces gens ont la
stratégie des coucous ils prennent nos
combats ils prennent nos luttes ils
prennent nos mots ils prennent nos
auteurs ils prennent nos autrices avec
Simone de beauoir réveillez-vous le RN
fait avec la santé des femme ce qu'il
fait sur tous les sujets du superficiel
de l'éphémère et de la démagogie quand
on gratte on découvre qu'il n'y a ni
travail ni empathie est-ce que les
femmes atteintes d'endométriose ne sont
pas perdantes aujourd'hui
euh non parce qu'elle n'aurait pas été
gagnante de toute façon avec cette
proposition loi pourquoi parce qu'en
fait elle ne correspond pas du tout aux
demandes des associations et au besoins
des femmes voilà clémentineotin qui
avait pourtant fait adopter une
proposition de résolution similaire au
texte du rassemblement national c'était
en janvier 2022 et à l'époque la
résolution était votée à l'unanimité le
RN accuse donc la gauche et la majorité
de sectarisme nous depuis le début de la
mandature à aucun moment on s on se sent
piégé parce qu'on ne regarde jamais qui
dépose un texte on vote dans dans le
sens de l'intérêt général ce que la
macronie et la nuupes font c'est de
toujours voter leur texte et de toujours
rejeter ce qui vient des autres alors
bon on comprend que le cordon sanitaire
tient toujours en tout cas pour la
grande majorité des députés le RN reste
infréquentable oui infréquentable pour
la gauche et la majorité hein c'est pas
le cas des républicains qui ont soutenu
ce texte cet après-midi ils ont voté
pour aussi la suppression ou la
suspension des allocations familial des
parents d'enfants criminels ou
délinquants alors ça n'a pas suffi hein
pour pour obtenir une majorité mais au
fond cette stratégie politique et bien
elle permet au rassemblement national de
prendre les Français à témoin pour
marquer des points ce soir le RN a
jusqu'à minuit pour tenter de faire
adopter des textes de sa niche
parlementaire l'interdiction de
l'écriture inclusive le complément de
revenu pour les étudiants qui
travaillent bon pas trop de suspense
Miriam he ces textes ont peu de chance
d'aboutir comme celui sur
l'endométrioseet merci beaucoup c'était
parfaitement clair merci Marco Vincent
vous vouliez nous éclairer sur
l'objectif
d'Israël clairement de tsal de tout le
pays éradiquer le ramas alors tel un
mantra le mot jait des lèvres de M
officiels israéliens é radication la
guerre engagée contre le Hamas martelait
encore hier soir la ministre du
Renseignement Guila Gamliel a vocation à
éradiquer le mouvement de la résistance
islamique de sortte dit-elle de
dissuader partout sur la planète les
djihadistes de semer la mort et
l'affliction incantation compréhensible
au regard de l'abjecte uté des carnages
commis par les tueurs surgis de Gaza que
promettre d'autres quand de plus il urge
de restaurer l'autorité en lambau d'un
chef de gouvernement Benjamin netanahou
comptable du fiasco sécuritaire le plus
dévastateur de l'histoire tourmentée
d'Israël et ce à la tête du cabinet le
plus droitier ça on le savait mais aussi
le plus incompétent qui est connu l'État
hébreu donc vous parlez d'incantation de
promesse impossible à tenir pourquoi
alors serment incantatoire en effet que
signifie éradiquer si se réfère à
l'étymologie latine éradiquer c'est
arracher une racine extirper supprimer
totalement un fléo une tumeur un péril
ce qui se pose dans nanilé les causes et
la matrice illusion racérénante mais
illusion quand même pas plus que le
Hamas le Djihad islamique le Hezbollah
libanais ou l'iranchit n'anéantiront
Israël Israël ne peut prétendre abolir à
jamais l'ennemi qui a juré sa perte même
si tsal son armée parvenait à quel prix
d'ailleurs à réoccuper l'intégralité de
la de Gaza où à la réduire à l'état de
ruine fumante hanté par 2 millions de
spectres un autre raccourci formulé par
netano lui-même mérite qu'on s'y arrête
le Hamas clairon virtuose de la
redemontade c'est daesh et nous allons
le détruire comme le monde a détruit
daesh le monde aurait donc pulvérisé
daesh voilà qui je le confesse m'avait
échappé certes le fantasme du califat
iraco-syrien a vécu mais si l'état
islamique est mort et enterré son
cadavre bouge encore que l'on songe au
ravage de l'eigs l'État islamique au
Grand Sahara dans l'air sahélienne et à
ceux perpétrer par ses filiales en Libye
Somalie Nigéria Mozambique Afghanistan
Pakistan Yémen Indonésie ou Philippines
n'en jetez plus la morgue est pleine
donc ramass égal daesh c'est une autre
formule que vous trouvez veine oui j'ai
terminé d'ailleurs par une de ces
objurgations martiales invoqué chaque
fois que de l'inommable nî la sidération
on ne négocie pas avec les terroristes
on les écrase soyons clair vous ne
trouverez dans mon propos aucune trace
d'indulgence pas une HCE de relativisme
ou d'euphémisation de l'atrroce mais
l'impératif de lucidité commande
d'admettre que la morale du tel en
souffrir on finit par négocier avec les
terroristes ou ceux ainsi désignés la
France de Charles de Gaulle l'a fait
avec le FLN algérien l'Afrique du Sud de
la partade avec l'ANC version Mandela
les États-Unis avec les talibans afghans
et Israël avec l'OLP de Yasser Arafat
incarnation Oni de la terreur en son
temps mais aussi avec le Hamas lui-même
qu'il s'agisse de conclure un cesser le
feu ou une Houdna une trêve en arabe je
sais bien que le temps est au deuil au
larmes et à la rage j'entends que les
appels à la vengeance couvrent les voix
de la raison mais au bout du bout du
malheur il faudra se rendre à cette
évidence au Proche Orient il n'y a
d'autres issu que la formule à deux
états l'alternative est au fond assez
simple ou deux états ou un seul l'état
de mort clinique de toute espérance
merci Vincent d'un tout petit mot vous
vous êtes d'accord avec cette approche
cette analyse on a besoin des
journalistes plus que jamais c'est vrai
je pense qu'on a besoin de compter
actualiser ce qu' peut le l Dieu sait
que c'est un casse-tête absolu he et que
ça doit être très très très très très
compliqué je vous dis juste en 2
secondes parce que moi j'ai j'ai échangé
avec très très rapidement avec des des
lcéens dans une petite ville de Bretagne
j'étais en zoom avec eux hier et et ils
m'ont dit pour certains d'entre eux j'ai
éteint la télé je voulais pas regarder
ce qui se passait tellement c'était
violent et tellement je ne comprends pas
aussi et ils ont le droit de le dire
qu'ils comprennent pas bah nous on a le
droit de leur dire qu'on essae très
modestement tous les uns et les autres
de donner un contexte c'est compliqué
mais c'est important fondamental on a
besoin des journalistes on a a besoin
des philosophes également Nathan de vert
vous vouliez aussi revenir sur ce qu'on
a du mal à à nommer on voit bien que
c'est un vide l'engagier qui s'offre
devant cette horreur absolue ceci n'a
pas de nom vous vouliez reprendre cette
formule oui tout à fait cette formule
c'est ce que j'ai penser et je pense à
mon avis ce que beaucoup de gens ont
pensé et ressenti surtout en voyant les
images et j'insiste les images pas le
récit les images de l'attaque du Hamas
samedi ceci n'a pas de nom mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire qu'un
événement n'est pas de nom s'agit-il de
dire qu'il est inommable autrement dit
qu'il est trop terrible pour pouvoir
être exprimé qu'on s'entient à l'émotion
pure s'agit-il de dire qu'il est
ineffable ça veut dire qu'il est trop
bizarre trop complexe trop imprévisible
pour pouvoir être compris et donc qui
serait incompréhensible or là
l'expression ceci n'a pas de nom elle
fonctionne au sens littéral ça veut dire
que si on réfléchit à la manière dont
cet événement est nommé par les médias
on voit bien qu'il y a une certaine
forme de flou on parle tantôt d'attaque
du Hamas tantôt de massacre du Hamas
tantôt de guerre Israël Gaza tantôt
d'attentat et l'article Wikipédia parle
d'attaque du Hamas contre Israël donc
voyez-vous on n pas un terme générique
comme la guerre de Kipour comme la
guerre des 6 jours alors c'est peut-être
trop tôt mais en tout cas et puis sur
les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant de voir que les hashtags
aussi font qu'il n'y a pas de
réversibilité du du sens selon qu'on est
dans un camp ou dans l'autre on va
parler de massacre de Gaza ou massacre
des des kibuts or en général les
massacres de notre époque il faut
remarquer quand même que ceux qui
n'avaient pas de nom on leur en a donné
un mais qui est un nom toujours
métonymique donc le massacre du du
Bataclan par exemple métonymie par le
lieu Charlie par la cible et surtout le
drame inaugural du 21e siècle le 11
septembre qu'on ne désigne plus comme
l'attentat des tours jumelles ce qu'il
était pourtant mais par sa date
c'est-à-dire par un événement enfin par
sa dimension entre guillemets la plus
contingente et en 2001 justement derida
avait fait ce livre qui s'appelait le
concept du 11 septembre où il disait que
précisément nous rentrions dans une
époque où les événements excédaient
toute conceptualité prédonné et donc que
pour les appréhender il fallait renoncer
à la grande grille conceptuelle de que
la philosophie de l'histoire a pu
édifier alors ça veut dire qu'il faut
renoncer à
Camu mal nommé le monde c'est rajouté à
son malheur il me semble que ça ça
presque la conclusion inverse et qu'on
voit bien justement que dans la
confusion qui a été la nôtre il y a un
moment par exemple où le langage est
très important c'est la qualification
juridique or certains ont voulu nier le
caractère terroriste de ces attaquesl
avec toutes sortes d'arguments on n'a
pas le temps de les reprendre tous un
argument de dire que c'était une branche
armée d'un mouvement plus large or vous
parliez de daesh daesh n'était pas que
une branche armée c'était aussi daesh
Pierrejean luizard le rappelait dans son
livre c'est construit contre la
corruption irakienne donc il y avait
aussi une dimension socio-économique
dans daesh sinon ça n'aurait pas marché
deuxième argument aussi c'était de dire
que le terrorisme si on employait ce mot
c'était oublier le contexte or
évidemment les attentats terroristes que
ce soit le Bataclan que ce soit Charlie
et cetera ont toujours un contexte
troisième argument qui à mon avis est le
principal c'était de dire que parler de
terroriste de terrorisme reviendrait à
donnner en chèque en blanc au
gouvernement israélien or il me semble
que dans cet argument il y a deux choses
qui sont très très problématiques la
première c'est que au contraire parler
de terrorisme ça suppose d'avoir une
expérience critique non seulement de
expériences de terrorisme qu'on a connu
mais des réponses qui ont pu être donnés
je citais deridas derida critiquait déjà
en son temps la logique de
l'auto-immunité qui gagnait la politique
américaine après le 11 septembre et
surtout c'est que cet argument il semble
trahir l'idée selon laquelle les mots ne
devraient pas être évalués en fonction
de leur véracité mais en fonction de
leur effet performatifs comme s'il
étaient uniquement des armes mais il me
semble ici que le langage doit être
défendu comme un vecteur de de précision
et donc de
merci beaucoup on va réécouter cette
chronique absolument François Xavier
ménage et moi sur les réseaux sociaux
sur la chaîne Youtube d'lcp merci
infiniment les affranchis pour vos
parties prix merci Marco Pomier et merci
à vous merci à vous François gavier
ménage ça craque c'est-à-dire chez
Robert Laffond quand un reporter de
guerre et bien va à la rencontre des
Français dans une France explosive qui
se bat quand même restons optimiste
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
tout de suite votre soiré entaire avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien très belle soirée à
vous à
[Musique]
demain